what do the Five Pillars stand for and
uh why we pray to them don't pray the
Five Pillars so the Five Pillars are the
what they call the pillars I mean the
pillars of Islam okay so Islam is based
on these pills so for example the first
one which is the most important
one which is to testify there's no one
worthy of worship except Allah the
second one to testify that Muhammad is
the last messenger and the servant of
Allah so this is the first pillar okay
so that's how the person becomes a
Muslim and all the other pillars and
actions are based upon the first pillar
okay and why is important because Allah
the creator of everything he has
legislated these pillars for his
religion so sometimes you know the
wisdom behind it sometimes we don't know
but of course the we can see the wisdom
of the sh 10 is to testify that you cuz
God when he create us give us free will
okay so God give you free will either
you accept or reject so how can you
accept you have to confess it okay you
believe with your heart but believing
with your heart is not sufficient you
have to confess it so how can you
confess that uh uh how to enter to the
religion of God which has chosen uh or
the Rion that Allah has chosen for his
servant is to to testify the first pill
up which is the two testimony the other
pillar which is prayer prayer why God
legislated prayer for us not because
God's in need of our worship rather
because we are in need of worshiping God
you understand the example I give
imagine I saved your life okay of course
you're going to thank me for saving your
life if I said to you look I don't need
your thanks to me know you deserve it
you save my life the best example
belongs to Allah so Allah
deserves our worship our appreciation
our obedience to him okay understand and
there's other people of course charity
charity which is zakat is good for for
us socially likewise economically you
know so likewise fasting fasting is good
for you physically mentally spiritually
likewise the hjj the HJ is good for you
physically mentally spiritually likewise
What's um what's the H the H when you go
to Mecca and do pilgrimage yeah also
there's many benefits in as well so we
Muslims Islam is based upon Brotherhood
and Sisterhood as well so like uh we
pray five times a day so we come to
mosque we meet each other okay so this
called a daily meeting okay there yearly
meeting which is the greatest one is the
ha one so you go when you go to Mecca
you meet brothers from different part of
the world you know
pakistanpakistan Tajikistan Algeria
Morocco
Portugal Africa you know countries you
know so so there's many many wisdoms and
many benefits uh behind the legislation
of
Allah make sense yeah alhamdulillah I
have some a couple of questions as no
problem okay how do you pray properly so
how do we pray of course I can't go in
details but how we pray we pray
according to the prophet
Muhammad this is a good question you
know why because some Muslims they think
the way to pray is just by following
people no we Prophet Muhammad taught us
how to pray Prophet Muhammad said pray
as you see me praying how Prophet
Muhammad prayed we have in our books
like Lally behind me we
havei this the most authentic book book
after the Quran so in this book there's
many
narration describing to us in details
how the prophet Muhammad used to pray
and we pray like Moses Jesus Abraham
Noah Jacob all the prophets and
Messengers they prayed like if you read
the Bible you can see Abraham put his
head down yes even there some Jewish
people now from Yemen other countries
they pray exactly how the Muslim pray
you know so the the description of
prayer some uh is in the Islamic books
but there is some small books it shows
you even with pictures how to pray okay
and even the prayer look when we pray so
we stand before Allah we
allahar yes mean Allah is the greatest
okay the scholars mentioned why do we
say Allah abbar mean here that now is a
time to stand before your creator so any
problem that you have in your mind any
trouble anything Allah is greater than
it so when you say Allah when you
allahar meaning that Allah is greater
than anything else so when you
understand the meaning of allahar you
know Allah is the greatest then you have
nothing to worry about so you're Focus
so even you bow down when you bow down
that's why islamically will not allow to
bow down to anyone except to Allah
likewise prr him so when you pray in
Islam you pray physically mentally
spiritually you know everything has to
be that's what one of the pillars of
prayer one of the pillars of prayer is
to have what they call it
Tranquility to to focus to understand
that you standing of course human beings
sometimes you Satan comes upay with your
mind and so on but you stand you
standing before whom before Allah the
greatest the creator of everything so
when you stand in and remember when you
the Quran you understand the meaning of
it it gives you more more
Tranquility all
right uh yeah a couple of these he
actually answered already but
uh which one why is it haram to listen
to
music why is Haram to listen to music
firstly what I say to you Thomas yeah
Thomas yeah what I would say to you look
like I said sometimes we can know the
wisdom behind something the reason okay
sometimes we don't know all right but
what we do know for fact without any
doubt Allah is the all wise Allah has a
perfect knowledge so when Allah
legislate something for us and when
Allah makes something Haram for us there
is wisdom behind it sometimes we know it
sometimes we don't know it the example I
can give you imagine you go to your GP
all right sometimes the GP would give
you some medication
you want to understand you want to comp
why is telling me to take this
medication or to to to do this to do
that doesn't make any sense to me the
problem is not with the GP himself the
problem is with us due to our uh uh lack
of knowledge and lack of comprehension
that's why we don't get it yes so but
what we know for a fact you know that
the GP has more knowledge than you and
the GP is more uh qualified
and he knows okay so therefore you
thinking know he has qualification he's
qualified he knows better than me so I'm
going to listen to him generally
speaking of course cuz some people say
no no we don't have to listen to GP
which I agree GP is not perfect but I'm
Give an example the analogy yeah so so
now but you say you know what he knows
better than me you understand so he's
more qualified he's more experienced so
what about Allah okay so that's called a
general response I'm responding the
specific response to why music is Haram
cuz music diverts you from the
remembrance of Allah like that's one of
the scholar said he said no way it's
impossible for you to be listening to
music and with the Quran in the same
heart one of them is going to overpower
the other one you know and the music is
like is like a is like tool that Satan
utilize to misguide the people you know
that's why we listen to music people get
hyper especially like hip hop or drill
music or every music you know it sends
away from Allah when you start I us to
listen to music one of the my biggest
problem when I started practicing Islam
after I came out Joe I used to always
think you know what bro it's hard for me
to stop listen to music man music is a
big F bro I used to bro I need I need to
try my best but alhamdulillah step by
step what I would say to you brother
don't focus on this secondary issues you
know the first one is the foundation you
know because someone being a Muslim and
listening to music is a billion times
than someone who was not not a Muslim
why I tell you why I can give you
analogy but of course we never be able
to even bring a closer to Allah's right
over us imagine I have two sons yeah or
you have two sons yeah one of them he
said yeah you are my father you know but
sometimes he disrespects you now and
then the other one he he rejects you
said I forget it who you you know even
though what you did you took care of him
when he was young you treated him nice
you you you you your your you looks
after him yeah which one is worst the
one who rejected you and abandoned you
turn away from you or the one who knows
your right but he's now he does
something which is
evil what is a good question the one who
rejects you yeah the one who rejects you
said you're not my father even though
you are his
father okay yeah yeah Fair know yeah cuz
but but if he knows and he's
still and he's still going against
now and then due toan cuz he's not
perfect yourself you have to you say you
know what I know my son you're not
perfect even you going to make excuse
for him but the other one he's rejecting
everything so the other one is is worse
you with me and of course this is
nothing compared to Allah because your
father doesn't own you in a way he never
gave you life you know your us our own
existence Everything Is by The Virtue of
Allah that's why the biggest crime
against Allah turn away from allaha when
you worship someone beside him that's
why disbelief and pism is the worst sin
because also disbelief and and and and
the and pism it boils down to
arrogance but when someone does some
sins he boils down to following desires
you know he's not arrogant towards his
creator he just sometimes you know he's
feeling down Satan deceived him you know
what I'm saying yeah that's why I
disbelieve and pagan is the worst so
being a Muslim listening to music which
is har is a billion times than someone L
to Muslim because that sin is a sin no
doubt but not not being a Muslim and
turn away from God is the the worst sin
like you mentioned before I think you
mentioned before in one of your lectures
where the pagans during the time
ofam they used to use music to divert
people from his calling yeah true yeah
music was used at the time Prophet
Muhammad wasallam said to turn people
away from Prophet Muhammad yeah so music
is dangerous man I mean like step by
step you can stay away from it you know
music TS you away from your God from
your Creator and we don't have a long
time here you know we can live this life
any time we can die any times we have to
prepare ourselves to meet our creator
but if you listen to music now and then
doesn't mean you're not Muslim anymore
you know you make to repent to Allah but
you don't have to expose yourself cuz in
Islam ald not like Christianity
Christianity if you commit sin you have
to go to the pop go to the father you
know in Islam yeah yeah cuz my wife is a
re as well she became Muslim she was a
Catholic you know Christian andhd Islam
if you commit sin you don't have to tell
everyone online I commit sin now repent
Allah Allah forgive me I was weak you
know try your best to not go back to it
and you have to hate the sin and you
know this Prophet Muhammad
said you know like aim and try to hit it
closer you know try your best you know
we try all of us have try our best you
know even myself don't think I'm perfect
I'm make no mistakes I'm human being you
know we forget sometimes we get angry
sometimes you know Satan deceive us yeah
that's why alhamdulillah one of Allah's
names is the most merciful the most
beneficent Al what is Al he's not just
loving he will do things for you to gain
to gain your love even though he's not
in need of your love that's why Allah's
name is Al you know not just loving no
it's just more than
that thank you you're welcome thank you
very much you're welcome do you have
other questions uh no I think I think he
answer the rest of them well thank you
very you have what no that's that's say
no more question so you read to become
Muslim yes alhamdulillah so I will say
to you in Arabic okay were you Christian
before yeah yeah okay okay say after
mea isaa Isa Isa yeah Abu
in English I bear witness after me I
bear witness I bear witness there's
nothing there's nothing worthy of
worship worthy of worship in truth in
truth except Allah except Allah and I
bear witness and I bear witness that
Muhammad that Muhammad is the last
messenger is the last messenger and the
servant of Allah and the servant of all
and that Jesus and that Jesus Son of
Mary son of Mary is a servant is a
servant and the messenger of Allah and
the messenger of Allah alhamdulillah my
brother I'm happy for you let me give
you a hug brother let me give you a hug
bro stand up for
you no worries brother happy for you
bro give you glad man Allah
bless
careful you're going to
be
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah it's a
blessing brother you can it's a big
blessing bro sit sit down sit down
alhamdulillah you know Prophet Muhammad
taught us when someone become a Muslim
all his sins forgiven so except if you
had the debt or you talk something from
someone unjustly then you have to give
it back but whatever between you and
Allah is Forgiven and alhamdulillah you
know today whole family uh become Muslim
from America mother with had two sons
yeah yeah alhamdulillah mother with had
two sons become Muslim aldah Islam is
submission you know Christianity is gone
and is dying like you know and when you
become a Muslim now you are believing in
Jesus the son of Mary the Messiah the
way Jesus want the people to believe in
him not like Christianity when you're in
in Christianity you are believing in
Jesus according to the Pagan ways you
know so alhamd I'm very happy for you
and one of the blessings you have the
brother here can help you to learn more
study in how you live he lives far from
you I'll be honest from where I
live yes bro a lot of Muslims there
you're not he's not far you're not far
from uh I live in Wy no no he's not far
from uh the brothers in uh t t yeah I've
never been there yeah MIT yeah you're
not I used to work in yeah I used to
work I to do construction next to the
shopping center yeah back in
2008 long time so that would have been
when the wi is coming up or something
like that isn't it what is it the wi
gift W gift no no it's not we just do
construction
laboring I don't know but we used to
walk there it's nice I like but the how
is the the crime
rates still bad I mean it's it's more
safe than people think like people think
C and
yeah is okay it's not it's not yeah
alhamdulillah I mean like even the time
when I us to work 2008 they say very bad
area but safe man walking I think you
know everywhere's not it's crazy l i
crazy alhamdulillah man I have to go
pick up my
daughter brother Thomas may Allah bless
you brother you thank you see
you